Kyle protec guy let's see you get good
you good or want to go here it's
probably even better right look I
understand light now do you I
oh I can use to grow my business in such
a crowded marketplace there's a computer
repair companies out there
it seems our ganger 20 question
Kyle Google AdWords it will just work
people are trying to find that stuff
plus you have to put out content I see
your face you can do it put out little
40-second tips on how to repair I'm
about to give really good advice that I
want all of you to pay attention to come
on
see the thing that people don't realize
is you want to teach people how to fix
things without paying you for it because
that builds up leverage you give up a
sale in the beginning but you get all
the sales in the end see that's what
people don't understand is that um with
Wine Library TV I was panning wines and
not selling those individual wines which
I had a lot of inventory of but it was
bigger than that I was becoming
America's wine guy I became a trusted
resource so for Kyle in the computer
repair space if he puts out 30-second
videos on Facebook and on YouTube and
10-second clips on snapchat and
15-second clips on Instagram or
infographics and pictures or
step-by-step tutorials about how to fix
little things that are common mistakes
Kyle at this point in your career you've
seen the same mistake fifty one hundred
five thousand times and instead of
hoping you get one of them to pay you a
hundred bucks to do something I'll take
you a second why don't you educate the
masses then you start getting authority
and trust then that becomes deal flow
for bigger business that's the way I'm
doing this right I'm giving away so much
stuff that people charge eighty nine
dollars for an e-book or ten thousand
dollars a year for a mastermind we're
all the cliche cliche [ __ ] my only
monetization of my information is a $19
book once every three years but in but
all the askgaryvee all the dailyvee I'm
just trying to educate educate educate
bring value and you build up trust and
guilt doesn't matter fact do you know
how devastated I am that so many of you
are only gonna buy one or two books when
I'm like damn it why don't you like four
to six it kills my thesis you have to be
okay with leaving a lot of action on the
table there's so many guys and gals that
give you a third of the quality that I'm
giving you
yet you're paying them for $250 of
courses or books and then when I put on
my free book you buy one for nineteen
and I see that every day
but that doesn't [ __ ] me because you
have to understand doing the right thing
in a net-net game is always the right
thing I may use the micro battle and we
get this very clear to you I am losing
the micro battle a lot of my
contemporaries are people that are one
for talented his needs building a
personal brand like poaching selling
courses
selling information you have if you're
selling snapchat advice right now
snapchat I saw on Facebook already there
you know a snapchat guide for $89 and
you know many people are buying them
tons and do you know where that guy got
all his snapchat advice from right and
yet some of you bought that I seen I've
seen it I've actually looked at people
like just got it great and literally
quit me I know that name
and looked and yet you comment on my
wall do I know you I know you you bought
that for any nine I'm giving it away for
free and then you're gonna buy one copy
of the askgaryvee book so I'm losing the
micro battle I'm losing the battle to
win the war get it I'm not trying to
make the dollars right this second I'm
trying to build up leverage I'm the one
showing up on the cover of magazines I'm
the one showing up on big TV networks
I'm the one who's built a hundred
million dollar agency business on the
backbone of this because I'm the advice
I'm the skills I've got the chops and
does it hurt my feelings that I don't
win the micro game do I feel that I've
given more than others and deserve to
sell a million books instead of 150,000
200,000 300,000 that I'm gonna get do I
feel like there's people that are
selling and making 8 9 10 million
dollars and selling you a [ __ ] dream
and giving you headline advice do I know
for a fact that there's so many people
that are just watching my [ __ ]
repackaging it and selling it for $200
ebooks and making more money on their
community than I am on my book yes but I
don't care because first of all it feels
nice to be on the right side of history
it feels nice to see the comments from
all of you that get it
and
and I think eventually one day I'll win
the micro battle somehow I haven't
figured it out but rather take the war
anyway